los vídeos anteriores de esta serie han
sido una exposición continua sobre
nuestros genes y como nuestros genes y
nuestro entorno están relacionados con
nuestro comportamiento y decir que los
genes y el entorno o medio ambiente son
importantes es realmente cierto pero más
específicamente estos interactúan y he
aludido a esto anteriormente con el
ejemplo del té y el agua caliente pero
aquí voy a ser realmente específica con
el lenguaje porque nuestros genes y
nuestro entorno no sólo afectan nuestro
comportamiento sino que su efecto
depende el uno del otro
digamos que tenemos dos bebés en el
cunero de un hospital uno está
genéticamente predispuesto a ser mucho
más atractivo que el otro entonces
tenemos al bebé atractivo y tenemos a
este bebé realmente horrible y como
resultado el bebé hermoso recibe más
cariño y más atención por lo que crece
para ser en general más sociable y bien
adaptado pero supongamos que al hacer
ambos bebés comparten una combinación de
genes que predispone a la depresión como
hemos aprendido el medio ambiente activa
estos genes en este caso quizá los genes
son activados por estresores ambientales
ambos bebés tienen estos genes pero a lo
largo de su vida este bebé lindo y ultra
adorable está rodeado por una gran red
de apoyo lo que reduce su estrés por lo
tanto sus genes no son estimulados para
crear la combinación de
neurotransmisores y otras proteínas
involucradas en la depresión pero por
aquí el bebé feo está produciendo esta
proteína sin parar y tal vez sea porque
se están burlando de este bebé todo el
tiempo o tal vez porque tiene menos
amigos así que suponemos que los genes
de lindo bebé son algo responsables de
establecer el medio ambiente pero
también el medio ambiente es responsable
al menos en cierto grado de mantener a
raya estos genes de depresión del mismo
modo en el bebé menos afortunado sus
genes juegan un papel en su vida difícil
y esa vida difícil activa los genes que
están asociados con la creación de los
neurotransmisores de la depresión este
es un ejemplo crudo de cómo los genes y
el medio ambiente interactúan entre sí
pero un ejemplo más específico es la
condición genética p count of en el set
o nuria y la fenilcetonuria es una
condición genética en humanos causada
variaciones en un gen que codifica una
enzima hepática y esa enzima hepática es
la fenilalanina hidroxilasa es decir fh
pero debido a que a la enzima le falta
el aminoácido fenilalanina no se
convierte en el aminoácido tirosina
durante una de las vías metabólicas en
nuestro cuerpo y esto provoca una
acumulación de fenilalanina en el cuerpo
que puede causar problemas en el
desarrollo del cerebro e incluso otros
problemas la pec aún afecta a 1 de cada
15.000 bebés en los eeuu pero la mayoría
de estos bebés crecen sin mayores
problemas pues resulta que durante el
tamiz genómico infantil estos bebés son
identificados y reciben una dieta
especial libre de fenilalanina entonces
debido a que no están tomando toda esta
fenilalanina van a tener una acumulación
menos problemática de la fenilalanina en
el cuerpo nuevamente es una interacción
entre nuestros genes y nuestro entorno
lo que inicia las respuestas y el
comportamiento del cuerpo vemos que el
entorno depende de la predisposición
genética pero la expresión génica
también depende del entorno y este es el
fenómeno al que nos referimos como
e interacción en entorno entonces esta
idea va a eliminar de nuestro
vocabulario frases como naturaleza
versus crianza nos llevará a una
fraseología más correcta la naturaleza a
través de la crianza